what's going on everybody welcome to
part 2 of our discord pie bot tutorial
in this tutorial we're just gonna start
building out an actual bot the only
thing that's changed from the last
tutorial is I've just started saving the
token in a file so I don't have to show
you guys my token and I don't forget
about it and all that so let's go ahead
and get started so the first thing that
we probably want to do immediately out
of the gate is right now when we break
our client the bot doesn't exactly log
out for quite a while sometimes it like
I've seen it sit there for like an hour
so we definitely want to be able to like
have the bot leave at some point so for
example we could do that as simple as
get out of here two exclamation marks in
message content lower or you could do
double equals even to make it like a
command then what we want to do is
rather than message send we could await
a client dot close so anytime it's a KO
routine so if you go look at the docs
and it says it's a KO to teen you have
to await the co-routine if you don't
await it basically the it you know it'll
throw that command out but then you'll
carry on and forget all about it so you
would you just want to be a very good
idea
so we'll await client close and then
that's that so the first thing that
we'll do now is let's just go ahead and
save and run that real quick so I ran it
there's my bot and then what we can say
is what did I say to get out of here
double so get out of here
and there he goes he's gone so easy
enough so that's one thing we want to go
ahead and add to our bot now what I'd
like to do is so you could say you know
logout you know make it some sort of
command for your actual thought since
I'm calling mine sent a bot and this is
some sort of you know it's it's a Python
Channel it's a bot that's going to
reside on a Python Channel I'm just kind
of making everything like it's a method
so I'm gonna say if sent a bot dot log
out in message content dot lower I'm
actually not even sure I guess we well
we've done the client closed but we
haven't
oh wait client clothes and then we could
do like an exit or something but for now
I'm just gonna cancel that
okay so the next thing I want to do is
we come up to my channel and so let's go
ahead and start adding like so sent
about logout what if we want to get like
for example I want to start tracking
like users on the actual on the actual
server so one of the ways that we can do
that is with like by counting members
and then we can also do things like
seeing who's online who's idle who's
offline who's got like Do Not Disturb
all that kind of stuff so we can start
pulling in that kind of information when
we reference the actual guild now to get
your guild you just need your ID so
right click any server copy that ID and
that's the the actual ID for your guild
which is it used to be called a server
so if you're looking up like stuff that
you can do with that and you see an
example and it uses like client dot
server just know that that's you know
client get server it's now it's get
guild I'm not sure why they made that
change I meant I know discord is for
gaming but discord calls it server and
I'm not sure if discord plans to call it
guilt what but whatever okay so so
that's what we're gonna do so first of
all we're gonna say at least for me you
could say guild equals and it would be
easier for other people to read your
code but I'm gonna call it sent X guild
and you can call it whatever you know
your guild is called and I'm gonna do a
client that get guild and you get the
guild by the ID and i just right-clicked
my server and got the ID you also can do
like I forget what the command is there
is there's like a way that you can get
all the guilds I can't remember what it
is but anyway you could cycle through
all the guilds that your bot has access
to and then figure it out by name or
something like that or you can just
right-click it this way so once we have
the guild the next thing that we could
do is we can make a command that gives
us information about that guild so the
next question that we could say is and
in fact I think I'm going to we'll just
start calling these l if statements so
we'll start with if
so if sent a bot dot member count and
then in this case we're gonna say double
equals and then we probably should say
that here as well so rather than in
message content lower we're gonna say it
has to be exactly that because otherwise
it would be a syntax error right Oh such
a nerd
okay so syntax member counts if that is
your message contents dot lower and in
theory we could stop using lower because
it should be this exact command okay so
if it is that let's go ahead and a wait
message dot channel dot send and then
what we're gonna send is another F
string and and in fact we could send it
in these like the code blocks I think
that's right three of them yeah so you
could say and then make sense enough
string we could say sent X underscore
guild dot member underscore count now
initially my thought was to act to keep
this as an attribute as it is an
attribute here but then as I started
thinking about everything pretty much
everything else is gonna end up being
like a method and that was gonna be
really confusing so I'm gonna make it a
method if that bothers somebody which it
shouldn't but if it does you know what
to do so you can change it yourself so
actually I'm gonna say it's a Python
code block new line and then we'll print
out the member account so let's go ahead
and save that let's run that hopefully
we're all good
ok we've logged in one of the bots is
talking and let me come down here so now
if I call sent a bot member account so
if I dive member oh my gosh if I get
tough dues
he responds okay we've got eight
thousand one hundred and eighty-eight
members in the server and then let's go
ahead and do a sentiment logout
Centofanti
log out good day and like you anyways
okay so I'm wondering if if maybe what
we could do is I don't really know let's
see import sis and then sis type exit
I'm not sure if that's enough to cleanly
exit let's just try that really quick
[Music]
okay cool that way we're not hitting
that silly error anymore so we'll just
await client close and then we go ahead
and exit okay
so I that's pretty much all I really
want to cover in this one I do have one
more thing that's in the text-based
version of this tutorial and maybe what
I'll do is I'll just copy and paste it
there's really nothing fancy here that's
like new or a new concept so I'm just
think that's just what I'm gonna do so
I'm gonna just copy that
ah it did get me I gotta figure out how
to like close all this the threads when
you're like running asynchronously not
really sure anyways not my problem right
this instant tools cancel build if you
know the answer to that let me know
otherwise I'll probably Google it after
I'm done with this tutorial and figure
it out anyway
so the other thing that we could do is
Elif sent a bot so in this case Elif
sent a bot community report if that's
the you know the thing that we asked
what we can do is we can iterate through
all of the guild members and then each
member has a status attribute and
that'll be online offline it might be
idle it might be DND for do not disturb
and other things so I'm just gonna call
anybody who's idle or some other status
other than online or offline we're just
going to say that's idle so then what we
can do is and again I might want to call
this high but obviously with this way
for now we can worry about you can worry
about formatting that stuff later
there are various like markdowns that
you can use and stuff but we'll just
stick with this so let's go ahead and
run that and then I'm just going to copy
this and then I'll bring this over here
paste okay so this gives us the actual
realistic numbers so in this case
there's 20 267 people that are actually
on line 523 our idle busy or do not
disturb and then offline 7000 665
which is interesting because that
doesn't quite agree with this number
here this is 505 people are online I
don't know if that has to do with like
if they're invisible or something like
that which it very well made I don't
know so much someone again if I'm
missing something
comment below and let me know what I've
what I've done wrong but I'm pretty sure
that online works and then offline works
and then maybe I'm just throwing too
much into idle or something like that I
don't really know okay so I think that's
enough for this one and maybe I'll have
one more video as I continue to build
this out the problem is it's basically
just a bunch of this I mean you're
building out you know commands and then
those commands do things and then to
figure out what you can do with commands
you just check out let me pull it over
the API reference let's see here we go
so if you want to learn more about all
the things that you can do just check
out the documentation and there's a
whole bunch of stuff that you can do
here I might reserve the next tutorial
what I'd really like to do is like in
this community report I would like to be
able to start keeping track like maybe
run that every I don't know every 30
minutes or ten minutes or something save
the results to save the results to maybe
like an SQLite or even just like a CSV
file and then later you could create
graphs and then instead when you do the
community report it would be a report of
graphs instead and then the the bots can
attach files if you give it the
permission so it could attach a file of
the graphs when you actually call it
community report you can see graphs over
time so I might do something like that
for the next video because like I said
at some point it's just a bunch of these
simple commands there's nothing too
fancy about it I did do a search maybe
I'll do that if you guys want to see how
I like implemented the search but
basically that was just a scrape of
Python programming nets some regular
expressions and boom the search works so
yeah let me know if you want to see the
search otherwise I'll probably reserve
the next part three to be
probably an upgraded community report
where over time we kind of saved some of
this stuff also if you see this is just
because you're in yeah like sublime or
something if you run this in a console
it'll just show like little squares and
you won't really you won't get an issue
like that oops so anyways that is all
for now quick shout out to my most
recent amazing members Michael Lau Jang
Joseph Coleman Siva Gabi and ampere
hammer thank you guys very very much for
your support if you didn't know how to
support and become a member you just
click that beautiful button right there
it's got nice stars around it and stuff
join boom done so anyways helps me keep
doing what I do I can put up more
content quicker the more I can focus on
this rather than doing things like
contracting and consulting so definitely
check it out if you want to support the
the channel in the content also you get
early access to videos just like this
one so that's all for now questions
comments concerns whatever feel free to
leave them below or you can join our
discord discord dot GG slash Syntex
otherwise I will see you guys in another
video